[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off the record
we talked about what we found the kitty
outside during our lunch break and the
kitty was just hiding under the tire
under your tire
who found it how did you find this I'm
making a phone call
I hear meow he's me I'm like whatever
dude and then I look on the floor so I
always look at the floor and then he was
right there underneath Bart's big-ass
tire and imagine if you didn't go on the
phone call today you would have ran over
the kitty yeah I don't want it luckily
the cat was like on the side of the tire
where you always drive forward before I
go backwards I've got oh no I'm saying
cuz then you could see it because if you
decided to hide behind this hair never
smile so don't pay attention yeah
doesn't even pay attention when there's
like poles and [ __ ]
yeah I would never have looked in front
of the tire I never do I'm like how many
hours have you killed squirrel the other
day what you did know so we were this
was maybe like three or four months ago
we were driving to go hike it was with
David and then there's these stupid-ass
squirrels I was lined up on the side of
the road why did I do that and they keep
doing this how about that sting right
what like they like they want to run
across but then they see a car so they
don't and then David I didn't I didn't
David let's say like what if funny
stupid squirrels joke think about it and
then you saw it happening right when
that happened this quarrel the squirrel
jumped right in front of me I swerved
and I came back but I still hit them and
then you just hear a crunch go under
and then we're like Devraj it Gingka
jinx us it was David's fault I was
jogging you ran over a squirrel with
their feet well I saw a flat squirrel
like a piece of paper it was flat and I
was like how the [ __ ] did this thing get
so dry and flat like jerky yeah it's
squirrel jerky it's like in the cartoons
and they get right over and it was like
in a [ __ ] cartoon shape - with a tail
off flat and everything flat I was like
if you throw it an angle so what I did
is we haven't named the kitty yet I vote
for Jake Kitty but I put it up there
pose I did a post on my Instagram I
became the uncle like you like no one
even asked you but you already like
you're all four names I decided you know
why not ask everybody else and we'll
brainstorm this why not call it [ __ ] I
like [ __ ]
puss puss okay let's throw these out
there yogurt Mishka what Jonas he's
gonna be bear question my mom named her
cat Mushu
from Mushin yeah I didn't that cats
wanna sleep when you're rubbing it
between your thoughts
meow mean how about meow mean mochi once
you suspect my knee oh you like it do a
lot of people name their cats or dogs so
there's a lot of us all I can't but then
it seemed you like that was like all
[ __ ] what just cute Megan Freeman I like
that one I heard that one though
paperclip silver paperclip that's your
kid's name you can't use that you guys
you know better than that
xae yeah - twelve Moonbeam Scooby iceman
Terminator
how about dog what Wolfie oatmeal
why do people love mochi they love mochi
it's so basic I'm gonna say it alright
well they're all [ __ ] basic you'd be
like Corona - YZ chicken
her cat's name is just Cat Cat Cat oh
yeah she goes round cat can I had a dog
named dog oh yeah
that's pretty cool when I had the three
cats I didn't when I was fostering I
didn't name them why not it was too hard
to tell the difference between my first
dog I named him Jo Jo column and my
parents are you sure I was like no
that's the name I want were brothers
twins actually no it wasn't named dog it
was named boy because it was my my like
extended family's dog boy yeah that was
no the dog's name is boy what are you
gonna name in the deme
I don't know I'm open to suggestions
it's neatly now oh it asleep I feels
warm on your chest your heart what about
cuddles but then you don't know what it
is yet yeah so gender-neutral jkt men
Katy I feel like I could never talk
about my first pet's name because and I
would answer a bunch of my security
questions yeah I've never told anyone my
first pet all those questions on my
different like your your first street
name when your favorite teacher or all
my elementary school I never answer my
real like what it's actually asking so
it's like what elementary school did you
go to how do you remember oh I remember
then I'll be like I'll be like chair but
what if you died someone need to get
into her because they're gonna try to
answer the thing with what if he died
someone used to get into your account
yeah he has all my [ __ ] I'm not gonna
know the right chair i'ma write the real
elementary school I know yeah I figured
at least that one too like my mom at
Coleman changed all my [ __ ] like [ __ ]
actually I've done that where I've made
such a good password that I forgot it
what is it it's so easy to retrieve your
passcode last password now I gotta write
it down so convenient I like I don't
like I don't like small talk so like the
first thing I'll do when I come up to
someone Giulio what religion are you
you go straight to it just like
something deep thoughts deep dark deep
Todd I think that's like so like you go
straight to like so it's the meaning of
life what are you what is your stance on
abortion more like whenever you do every
single time have done that people
laughing either cuz they don't think
you're serious and you're like mom
serious well yes you really go what's
your religion when my roommates had
someone
yeah girl every time you see someone it
has to be a girl I don't know if you
guys know but I want to say who it's not
bad or anything it just he's horny broke
quarantine so so I met him when I was
like oh cool what religion are you right
yeah you just started laughing like like
it was pretty funny so work but I feel
like if I just asked like small talk I
would have been awkward you feel like
that's because we're in LA and people
are less religious stuff over here how
many [ __ ] fleas does that baby have
it's not three yeah
I can't believe in my helmet why is the
bassist from Red Hot Chili Peppers named
Lee you guys know oh yeah all right the
given name was flea flea Turton flea
dirt in these Irish bass guitar you know
musicians elude flea fleas pretty weird
I love flea though Anthony imagine he
was his name amp answers Anthony if they
called me like eater
they're like house your name is Joe and
it's not like I'm one of those badass
ones you don't like if I could feel like
I'm I like wasps how is Richard dick
yeah that's a that's a little what is
Jim James Jim and Jim you know for James
there's no 1 billion bombers of [ __ ] Bob
and Dick bop bops for Robert oh wait
you're right you're correct bob is
Robert and then Bill is William Bob
Marley Robert Marley
that's his birth name right
Roberts Molly I call him Robert I was on
a name like something where you wouldn't
think it's a column circle circle yeah
what's that cycle home Siri hey Siri
give him a name like [ __ ] Ilana
Google a one 5xw he did that joke like
months ago yeah don't you got a bunch of
hair near
you know dude
maybe I do what the beer you brought
leaves in here freezing here I've been
like trying not to scratch but I feel
like there's two did you know that the
Black Plague they were saying it came
from the fleas and then the please give
that rad disease into the human that's
the first coffee you gotta give that
Kitty a bath when you get home you're
gonna keep it you had to get to the bed
what if you see the mama like standing
up yeah I'll go overturn it it ain't
gonna need it but took a boy cat is that
like another stray hmm and you just left
you just assumed and you push the cat on
some on a did you assume that cat's
gender or is the cat mom mommy cats
boyfriend Oh like a deadbeat boyfriend
yeah but do you know what about mando
manga pubes ah
support for today's episode comes from
manscape manscape has the right tools to
get the job done quickly safely and
hygienic ly Father's Day is just around
the corner and you probably need a gift
for a hairy dad make your dad proud this
year and get him and yourself the
manscaped perfect package you know what
they say like father like son and I love
manscape because it has the little light
on there so I don't know where you guys
shave by shave in the shower and the way
to design showers in the modern world
it's not like they have lights
everywhere like from the bottom up not
like like the strip club and they don't
have mirrors on the floor or anything
like that so it's the little light helps
out because when I try to get to my ass
hairs I don't get all the way back into
my answers buddy some stragglers there's
some light so it does help me reach all
the way back there I appreciate that
light thank you so much man it's good to
so now I have hands-free operation as
before I spring a flashlight and those
trimmer Bernard just need to trim with
alone so manscape is the only men's
brand dedicated to the below the waist
grooming they have forever changed the
grooming game with the perfect package
three-point no and the perfect package
3.0 by manscape is the number one
recommended gift all year long and the
perfect package 2.0 kit comes with
essential lawnmower three-point unless
I'm talking
it's waterproof so you can using the
shower cord this body trim in a ton of
other liquid formulations to round out
your manscaping routine the third
generation tremors that really came out
with features a cutting-edge ceramic
blade to prevent manscaping accidents on
any part of the body hairy chest or back
there's certain races out there you know
who look no further
so stop imagining these painted imagine
your dad has it covered because he does
it cuz if you look at you then you know
what your dad looks like
so get 20% off free shipping with the
code off the record at manscape comm
that's 20% off with free shipping at
mass gabe calm and use the code off the
record it's dad boss season trying to
get smooth hey off the record you know
how I knew I was getting a little older
but we're 13 years older than you can oh
but again so so what does that mean he's
been old he's been born old
did you I feel like Afghan kids they pop
out of the [ __ ] with the beard I have I
was showing you guys like I have cousins
that are like 10 years younger than me
they have way better beers than I do
like cool beards you got so much
testosterone that's why he's so strong
how did you find out that you're getting
older so I was like okay let me do a
logical thing and I started saving some
money especially this time I was like
let me start shaving my [ __ ] so I
could save on wiping I don't have a
bidet I was like I know I like it
doesn't work like that it does
demonstrate maybe your butthole helps
how do you it's smoother cuz you got
like how many toes hit the wipe that
[ __ ] instead of like just getting [ __ ]
on like that's why dogs got
dingleberries oh when it's growing back
you know like sometimes it did you know
how like your skin touches each other
there's like a fault it doesn't it
doesn't like you only feel it cuz even
down here absolutely my pubic area when
it's going back itches
hey what you don't need when I grow my
hair back on my pube area like on my
dick it itches because it's like there
does yeah when I'm on the bajo no no
boho maybe cuz its moist well no you're
right that's true when i should'a get no
ingrown hairs or anything like that and
it's I can't even tell when it grows
back
how do you shave your [ __ ] yeah or
like with no demonstrated I go I can't
have a kitty on me kitty but that's not
why I thought I was getting old but but
limited it there outta my age rate but
hairs you have green how did you how did
you know he's shaving watching all I
could get gray I didn't either
aren't you 24 that's kind of young yeah
my fella greater you do you do oh yeah
more than me
I didn't realize it could be genetics
guys yeah no he's a stress I feel like
it goes in patterns with stress and
starts train I think I have some sense I
got stressed I don't know your hair
looks your hair's perfect [ __ ] you job I
got great I got great hair shut up just
put your [ __ ] hat on and hide that
perfect hair I hate you I feel like my
front doesn't show the gray like this
front doesn't short but in the back and
inside I have a lot on the front I hate
it
versus the opposite it's like inside its
colorful outside it's like it's like
bangs it's like reach bangs yeah it
sucks
go for it like just feel great cuz and I
look like a faded person no you don't
not even cool no I like I like looking
like I'm in like my like vivid like
saturation vivid saturation no no no I
try to look like storm but it's not all
it doesn't all grow out at once you're
you trying to be like Lady George
Clooney or mean the quail is good with
gray hair Anderson Cooper quietly you
ain't trying to be like Colonel at the
bill although she's all she's all she's
me too she's I'm down for the karela
didn't feel like that's the kind of old
lady you're gonna be but a good good
cross yeah and instead of Dalmatians
it's like something else
Oh have her her head is great I always
wanted to kind of like color my hair
like a silver or white or something but
then I'm afraid people are gonna assume
I'm a weeb and that's the wrong
assumption
I don't you can't be really sure if
you're Asian you can't you can't like a
lot of Byron's the ultimate weed ah
matters like the king of the weaves yes
mhm but it doesn't look as weird people
no no not like judging me but don't be
like they want to relate to me they're
like oh we let's talk about animes you
know what's dog get away i watch some
here and there they get out of here nerd
didn't even want that attention it's
like when someone has a flicker shirt on
the automatically beam wants to fight
all the time
oh it's like it's like people who wear
like Thrasher hats all the time you're
like oh [ __ ] you're a skater it's like
oh I just like this hat I saw this one
[ __ ] video is so funny it was like
this really hot like cosplayer right and
then this guy's like oh girl what's up
and he's like hi I'm a guy but like if
he didn't open his mouth I was like what
the [ __ ]
yeah because I mean that's the thing
when they cosplay right they just be
everybody in anyone when I had purple
hair and it was washing off it was
turning like gray
I crave silver I was like I could see
you add like an anime convention
cosplaying how long does it take for
hair to grow back though like to the
colors this is all my route like I
haven't I haven't bleep like this is all
my route from a how long like you're
like two weeks would be like this is a
year you guys and girls what the same
time yes oh really
it depends person to person to it's not
gender um some people's hair just grows
[ __ ] fast my mind goes pretty fast
too
this is the longest this is the longest
it's been and it's about almost two
months it's almost two months oh it's
almost the parking hair dude I'm gonna
have so much fun with just [ __ ] with
this cuz I never had hair like I've
always been bald or like super short you
know the part that I hate about hair
know like when you're like working out
or running I hate stuff all in my face
so it's hard for me to get long hair
where I don't even like Wayne I don't
like stuff I got like jewelry or just
too much time a French [ __ ]
I know why do I got it [ __ ] you gotta
get a turtleneck dude I know I just look
like a pervert every single time you
look sketchy get a win sound like I'd
ask you for drugs but my face it just
looks like I'm up to no good
maybe you gotta get it get it
professionally made over by someone they
know how to trim it the way so looks I
know you wouldn't look shady if you wore
green contacts I fail you look more
shady why it's Bobby your eyes I think
your eyes make you look shady yes lady
Chinese eyes yet look look look he's up
to something
you don't think the green would make it
worse what if I look like this down
every time Bobby does that no like a
racist caricature of yourself oh no all
right I got my looks I'm gonna probably
I'm gonna shave this eventually though
let get long-legged longer what if you
cleaned up and [ __ ] these parts
maybe I mean like what I had before it's
the same thing it's like a Keanu or
shave all this but not here here
oh this risk shave the mustache and
shave the goatee and only half the size
no that's down here we're like whiskers
just just here right here just get into
it I just love that's a new style
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]